[Musique
] être dans cette catégorie avec ces
femmes extraordinaires et Glenn Close Je
t'ai été mon idole pendant si longtemps et ce
n'est pas comme ça que je voulais que ce soit et je pense que
tu es incroyable et laisse-moi vraiment
tuer ça  est un moment monumental
[Music]
parfois il semble qu'il n'y a pas d'espoir
mais il n'y a qu'à parler
et nous nous rapprochons Je sais que ça
sonne ringard et comme vous savez
pollyannaish
mais c'est la vérité
[Music]
ce prix appartient  au Mexique ce film
n'existe pas s'il ne vient pas du Mexique
[Musique]
et l'Oscar va à oh mais c'est la
première cinquième nomination gagnante pour Spike
Lee
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]